Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge Das Podcast-Ufo. Das Charme-Ufo. Weißt du, wir haben auch das Wort Ufo auch nie mehr verdient im Namen. Wir sind einfach nur noch das Podcast, so ein Krümen, Krumen, das Podcast-Bröckel. Eigentlich sollten wir heute mit einem der intelligentesten Menschen der Welt reden, aber wir haben es nicht geschafft, unsere massive Inkompetenz. Die sucht mit, wie alt ist sie jetzt, 31, 32 32 sucht sie nach Sternen im All. Und findet die auch. Und findet Sterne im All, die ältesten Sterne. Wir finden nicht mal einen Audioeingang richtig bei Skype. Soundflower, Eingang, Ausgang. Wir haben es nicht gekriegt, Leute. Aber es ist auch kompliziert so, weißt du? Die haben halt Probleme wie so die Realitätstheorie, wie verschiedene Gammastrahlen, okay, und verschiedene Spektroskopie und dann, oh, da ist eine Wellenlänge. Weißt du, wir schlagen uns ein Problem rum, wie wir haben 64 Audioeingänge und wissen nicht, wo das von Audioflower jetzt landet und bei Skype, keine Ahnung. Ey, ich habe Audition nicht geupdatet, so das sind so Probleme, die die wahrscheinlich nicht haben, ne, die haben den heißen High-End-Scheiss mit ihren Satelliten. Die haben auch so Assistenten, denen immer alles geupdatet wird. Ja. Weißt du, die haben Leute, die das machen. Meine Festplatte ist so gut wie voll. Die haben die besten. Hat die NASA das Problem, dass ihre 100.000 Terabyte-Platte voll ist? Nein, die haben Felder, Felder voller Festplatten, wo so ganz einzeln nacheinander aufgereiht zu Festplatten sind. Weißt du, wir sind die Wissenschaftsfront, wir sind draußen im Dreck, im Schützengraben und graben noch die Diamanten aus. Sie da draußen in ihren grossen Türmen schicken Raketen in Weltall, wow, wir machen noch die harte kleine Arbeit, auf die es ankommt im Endeffekt. Ich hoffe wirklich, dass sie den Podcast, weil sie muss ja irgendwie davon erfahren haben, dass wir über sie gesprochen haben, daraufhin kam ja ihre Kontaktaufnahme, sie hat auch uns gefunden, wie Sterne im All hat sie auch uns gefunden. Sie findet alles einfach, sie findet einfach alles. Wenn sie Kontakt mit Leuten aufnehmen will, schafft sie das auch. Fremde Lebensformen, far away und auch uns. Und dann hoffentlich weiss sie ja, dass wir technisch nicht so ganz begabt sind und kann sich jetzt so ein bisschen ins Reinen... Das Einzige, was sie von uns weiss, das ist, dass wir einen Podcast machen können. Das ist alles. Das ist das Einzige. Und dass wir uns aber lustig machen, wie andere mit ihr ein schlechtes Interview machen. Aber der hat es hinbekommen, sie aufzunehmen. Der hat hinbekommen, die Zeit einzuhalten, nicht eh schon 15 Minuten zu spät zu sein, weil er vom fucking Dreh kommt, weil er es schlecht geplant hat, das ganze Interview. Nein, er hat es auch geschafft, sie aufzunehmen. Ja, Leute, ihr kriegt schon mit, wir sind sehr beschämt, es ist sehr unangenehm. Wir mussten den klassischen Rollover-and-Die-Move machen, indem er kann nichts, Hilfe, bitte geh weg, verschieben. Aber es war nicht mal ein Rollover, es war einfach ein Die. Es war einfach ein Stand there and die. Hast du gerade Pullmoll von mir genommen? Zwei. Pullmoll. Hmm, lecker, lecker. Wir sind so schlecht in so kleinen Sachen, so Organisationskram und so, das können wir überhaupt gar nicht. Da haben wir null Kompetenz.
So eigentlich alles, was soziale Interaktion, eigentlich brauchen wir ein Redaktionssystem. Also es ist langsam Zeit, dass wir ein Redaktionssystem, die uns das hier aufbauen und dann schieben die uns so in so Rollstühlen, schieben wir uns hier rein. Wir haben schon so ein Mikrofon in der Hand, einfach mit so Gaffer-Tape um die Hand gemacht, damit wir das auch nicht verlieren können oder so.
So ein Schlabberlatz, damit wir nicht mehr schlucken müssen und nicht mehr atmen können.
Einfach so eine Herz-Lungen-Maschine, einfach so, dass man uns hier ranschiebt und dann lasst man uns machen. Das wäre am besten eigentlich. Wir reden mal über das Rauswieseln, weil was wir gerade gemacht haben, war klassisches Rauswieseln und es gibt die verschiedenen Stufen des Rauswieselns, erstmal, ja das schaffe ich, kein Problem, passt schon, dann,, ich muss es verschieben. Einsicht, Einsicht. Dann, ich hab's verschoben, fuck, ich schaff's gar nicht, ich bin schlecht, ich bin grottenschlecht, ich hab jetzt schon viel zu viel investiert, die andere Person hat viel zu viel gelitten. Ist ein bisschen so. Dann, ich sag ab, Scham, Rollover and Die, ich streck alle Viere von mir, erfinde Lügen und dann kommt, ja, okay, passt und dann Ah, es ist ein bisschen wie die fünf Stufen des Trauerns, nur in anderer Reihenfolge, weil erst kommt das Leugnen, nö, ich schaff's noch, dann kommt die Einsicht, nope, auf gar keinen Fall, dann kommt so Wut auch auf sich selber so ein bisschen, dann kommt Verhandlung, halt man muss mit einem anderen nur einen Termin verhandeln und irgendwann kommt dann die Erleichterung und das Abschliessen mit dem Moment. Es ist wirklich die fünf Stufen, nur in anderer Reihenfolge. Ey, ich bin, äh, ich will mich am liebsten, ich will am liebsten so einen dicken Pulli jetzt anziehen, so mich kalt duschen, so einen dicken Pulli und im Zelt schlafen, so im Zelt schlafen, draußen, so wo niemand mich finden kann. Es ist mir gerade echt unangenehm, weil es ist die schlauste Frau der Welt, schlauste Mensch der Welt, die Sexismusfrau der Welt, wenn ich sind einfach so Idioten, die so einen Termin verbaseln. Apropos verbaseln, Basel haben wir auch verbaselt. Das ist auch ein anderes Thema. Willst du dich entschuldigen? Wir haben es verbaselt. Willst du dich entschuldigen? Ich will mich entschuldigen bei allen, die damit gerechnet haben, dass wir im Humorkongress ein bisschen Ramazama machen, dass wir da so eine coole Mats drehen, wie wir da hinlaufen und dann an den Messeständen da die Leute Karlauer erzählen. Aber auch so ein Zeitraffer, wo wir dann mit so lustiger Musik schnell um den auch so Schlangenlinien mässig ein paar Mal hintereinander um den Eingang laufen, so Polonaise. Wo dann wir in so einer Halle stehen, wo 200 Leute sind, die wir alle händisch zensieren mussten, die dann alle so schwarze Bälle im Gesicht haben. Wo wir dann so Interviews führen, wo wir immer nicht den Interview angucken, sondern mit vorgefertigten Fragen immer in die Kamera gucken und denen sie das Mikrofon hinhalten. Ganz ausgespreckten Armen. Und immer nur die Frage stellen, den Arm ausstrecken, dann war die Frage aber schon der Gag und dann, bevor er antwortet, schneidet man weg. Diese alte Matzschule, diese alte Rab in Gefahr, wir gehen raus Schule. Was ich auch mag, ist, wenn die Frage nicht selber gestellt wird, sondern eine Texttafel ist. Wenn die Texttafel ist, was erhoffen sie sich von 2017. Aber der Interview, der trotzdem im Bild ist, wenn man sagt, warum habt ihr das nicht, was hat er getan, dass er das rausmachen musste? Ja, scheiße Matzen, ey, ich hasse Matzen. Ich stelle dir erst die Fragen, die ich für Anna Frebel vorbereitet habe. Worüber, was ist, bist du noch, bist du eigentlich Science-Fiction-Fan, Florentin, also kannst du das, kannst du dich damit
noch, äh,
da bin ich fast froh, dass wir es nicht gemacht haben,
wenn solche dümmlichen Fragen von dir gekommen wären.
Nein, die habe ich nicht gemacht.
Lesen sie eigentlich auch gerne dann so
Science-Fiction-Romane von George Orwell?
So was, und dann
sagte er und las gerade aus seinem
Fragen Dialog vor.
Ich habe die Fragen, das hat mich echt gefreut, aber wir kriegen das noch hin. Ich habe mal in meiner Schulzeit, da gab es mal so eine Aktion, Schüler, Lehrer, Schüler, aka Lehrer werden entlassen, wir müssen Geld sparen. Aka Lehrer machen Urlaub. Und die Schüler sollen jetzt die anderen Schüler unterrichten. Dann konnte man sich freiwillig melden und konnte dann andere Schüler unterrichten. Also ich war dann, keine Ahnung, in der neunten Klasse und konnte dann fünf Klässler unterrichten und habe dafür Geld bekommen. Echtes Geld während der Schulzeit. Du meinst so Monopoly-Geld. Nein, echtes Geld, Euromark. Also was man dann so Schulgeld, was man am Computer abgeben kann. Echtes Geld, mit dem man sich auch guckt und Noten kaufen kann. Und das, da habe ich mir gedacht, das mache ich.
Und natürlich sagt man bei solchen Sachen zu und bereut es instant.
Sobald du deine erste Klasse hast und ich
habe mich wirklich, ich hatte keinen Bock mehr und ich
habe dann tatsächlich am Tag, bevor ich meine
erste Unterrichtsstunde haben sollte,
habe ich zu Hause, bin ich nachts, konnte nicht schlafen,
habe mich rumgewälzt, habe dann einen Brief
geschrieben, nachts,
hallo Frau Brückenbühl,
ich möchte, ich kann leider doch nicht
heute machen, weil ich Fahrschule
Vielen Dank. hab mich umgewälzt, hab dann einen Brief geschrieben, nachts, hallo Frau Brückenbühl, ich möchte, ich kann leider doch nicht heute machen, weil ich Fahrschule habe, ich möchte auch kein Geld dafür haben, danke, ciao, die wirklich schlimmste, erbärmlichste, demütigendste Nachricht überhaupt, hab die der ins Fach gelegt, beim Lehrerzimmerfach, hab sie dann persönlich noch getroffen, bevor sie es gelesen hat, so, ah Florentin, du hast heute deine erste Nachricht. Und die Nachricht lag im Fach und ich so, ah, nee, ich hab... Geil, wenn du sagst, ich mach's dann doch und dann irgendwie diesen Brief loswerden musst. Das war eigentlich eine geile Romantic Comedy Story. Aber sie meinte dann so, nee, nee, das musst du schon machen und so, ich hab denen jetzt das alles gesagt und so und dann, ja, und dann hab ich's doch gemacht, das war schrecklich, das war einfach Katastrophe, das war furchtbar.
Ey, aber es ist so ein bisschen dieses Jonglieren, dieses, man kann auch noch absagen, vor unangenehmen Sachen, auch bei meinem ersten Stand-Up, den wir auch zusammen hatten, da hatte ich das auch, dieses, du hast immer, du hast dieses Damoklesschwert, du kannst dich immer noch wie ein feiges Huhn, wie ein feiger Wurm, kannst dich noch entziehen. Und ich meine, du kennst doch auch bestimmt die Momente, wo du denkst, okay, ich habe morgen Termin, hoffentlich trifft ein Orkan Nordrhein-Westfalen. Und hoffentlich bricht hier alles zusammen, damit es funktioniert. Wir haben ja nicht die Hurricanes. Und ich denke mir dann immer, wenn du diesen Wunsch hast, solltest du da nicht absagen, wenn du dir geheim wünschst, du solltest es machen. Nee, manchmal ist es gut, sich aus der Comfortzone heraus zu bewegen. Und dann machst du auch gute Erfahrungen so.
Ja, eigentlich schon. Dann machst du gute Erfahrungen. Wir hätten jetzt gerade, wenn wir nicht abgesagt hätten, die Erfahrung gemacht, wie es ist, mit dem schlauesten Menschen der Welt zu telefonieren, ohne dass irgendjemand jemals mitbekommen wird, im Rahmen des Podcasts, den danach niemand hören kann. Und dabei macht es die ganze Zeit ...rrr, Krrrr, Krrrr, Krrrr, Krrrr, Krrrr, Krrrr, Krrrr.
Ey, wir haben einen Tontest gemacht mit Skype und es klang wirklich wie ein
Roboter mit Down-Syndrom.
Da bin ich da einfach komplett rumlallt.
Es klang ein bisschen so, als wenn man die Black Eyed Peas ins All schickt,
ein Alien das findet, ein Mixtape
daraus macht, einmal komplett um den
Uranus schickt damit und die Gase
das so zerfressen und es dann zurück zur Erde kommt.
Inwiefern Uranus und Gase?
Ja, da habe ich mich ein bisschen vorbereitet, weil das besteht ja
hauptsächlich aus Methan. Uranus schickt damit und die Gase das so zerfressen und es dann zurück zur Erde kommt. Inwiefern Uranus und Gase?
Ja, da habe ich mich ein bisschen vorbereitet, weil das besteht
hauptsächlich aus Methan. Ah, Uranus besteht
aus Gasen? Ja, ja, Helium und Methan
und so. Das ist ein Gasplanet, Gasriese.
Inwiefern, in wofür wird denn Gas
zusammengehalten als Gasplanet?
Naja, das ist auch so eine Masse, Massending.
Gas hat doch nur sehr wenig Masse.
Ja, aber im Vergleich
zum Vakuum, ich bitte dich. Gibt es auch Gas Monde? Lächerliche Vakuum. Oh Gott. Gibt es auch Gas Monde irgendwo? Nein, nein. Warum denn nicht? Nein, weil das sind zu klein, die können nicht die Steingärze. Gibt es nicht manche Monde, die grösser sind als manche Planeten in unserem Sonnensystem? Herr Will. So wäre das Interview abgelaufen, oder was?
Ich bleibe das.
Klassisches.
Womit man sich mit jedem.
Aber sie wurden mit der Tatwaffe am Tatort gefunden.
Ich meine, mit Waffe.
Man muss halt ein Wort noch so verstehen.
Und der Rest ist so Waffel. Waffel, Waffel, Waffel, Waffel. Man muss halt so ein Wort noch so verstehen. Und der Rest ist so Waffel. Waffel, Waffel, Waffel, Waffel, Waffel, Waffel. Ja, so ungefähr. Och mein Gott, ey. Gab es mal so eine Situation, wo du dich dann wirklich rausgewunden hast, dann wirklich, und das auch bis jetzt bereust? Weil ich meine, ist diese Entscheidung zwar im ersten Moment befriedigend, aber beim so mehrmöglichen Nachdenken denkt man dann auch so, ja, shit, eigentlich hätte ich es doch machen sollen. So eine klassische Reue im Moment. Nee, eigentlich nicht. Aus wirklich bedeutenden Sachen habe ich mich dann doch nicht rausgewieselt. Und ich glaube, das ist der Unterschied. Für mich war es zum Beispiel eine extrem große Überwindung, damals in den Schultheaterkurs zu gehen, weil ich mich ab und für Schauspieler interessiert, fand ich cool, aber komplett schüchtern, komplett no way, nur mit fremden Leuten im Raum, die in höheren Jahresstufen sind, auf gar keinen Fall. Aber irgendwann habe ich dann gesagt, ich habe die Entscheidung getroffen und dann glaube ich zwei Jahre später bin ich dann tatsächlich hingegangen. Du hast in zwei Jahren auch nicht geschlafen. Null. Ich habe diese Woche ein paar neue Podcasts entdeckt, und zwar wir sind ja immer wieder auf der Suche nach tollen, innovativen
Podcast-Ideen, und zwei Podcasts
möchte ich heute vorstellen, und zwar
der erste Podcast heißt
Revisionist History von Malcolm Gladwell,
und da geht es um
Geschichte, aber vor allem auch nähere Geschichte, und zwar
immer so um obskure, kleine Details,
kleine Geschichten, die er
recherchiert und ausgräbt,
und die immer so in 20 Minuten kurz Essays und Reportagen zusammenträgt. Irgendwie, das ist hochinteressant. Da ging es zum Beispiel um eine Statue von so einem Widerstandskämpfer, der damals zur Bürgerrechtsbewegungszeit gekämpft hat. Und dann stellt sich eben raus, dass die Person, von dem die Statue ist, überhaupt gar kein Widerstandskämpfer war, sondern nur zufällig bei der Demo dabei war. Und dann findet er halt die Person, die die Statue gemacht hat und dann deckt er halt auf, wie das diese ganze Erinnerungskultur eigentlich kommt, der Bullshit ist in manchen Sachen und das ist hochinteressant, sehr guter Podcast und 99% Invisible ist auch noch ein sehr guter Podcast, der ähnlich funktioniert, wo auch wieder so ein Journalisten-Redaktionsteam sich so ein paar Sachen rausnehmen und recherchieren. Und da ging es in einer Folge zum Beispiel um Emojis. Und zwar hat einer der Redakteure sich gefragt, wie denn neue Emojis entstehen und wie denn Emojis überhaupt gehandhabt werden. Und da hat er eben diese Organisation herausgefunden, die dafür sorgt, dass alle Emojis denselben
Code haben, weil es gibt ja zum Beispiel auch dann
Apple-Emojis und Samsung-Emojis, die sind
ja dieselben Bildchen,
aber die haben den gleichen Code. Genau. Das heißt, es muss
irgendwo... Es ist nämlich eine eigene Sprache. Es gibt ja mittlerweile
Aski-Zeichen, Alphabet, es gibt auch ein Emoji-Alphabet.
Genau. Da muss was aufgenommen werden, anders als
Buchstaben kann es auch noch erweitern, man weiß
ja nicht, was noch kommt. Absolut. Und irgendjemand muss ja kontrollieren,
dass der Code 18406 genau das Kerzen-Emoji ist und das Kerzen-Emoji bei allen Geräten ist, damit nicht der eine Apple-User ein Kerzen-Emoji schickt und beim anderen kommt dann ein Stern an. Das wäre ja verrückt. So, und da fragt man sich natürlich, wie entstehen neue Emojis, und das ist tatsächlich relativ simpel, die werden einfach gepitcht von normalen Leuten, können da ihren Pitch hinschicken und sagen, hey, aus diesen und jenen Gründen muss es diesen neuen Emoji geben und hier ist mein Case und der Redakteur hat das eben gemacht mit dem Beispiel des Yoga-Emojis, mit dieser Frau in dieser Lotus-Position, dieser Meditations-Yoga-Position und der hat dann eben den kompletten Prozess beschrieben und er hat es dann tatsächlich geschafft, dieses Emoji unterzubringen und so heißt auch die Folge Girl in Lotus Position oder Woman in Lotus Position. Also könnt ihr euch die Folge anhören, ist hochinteressant, ein sehr guter Podcast und ich dachte mir, wow, es ist möglich, sich selbst in der Internetgeschichte zu verebigen. Das ist total geil. Vor allem, weil alle benutzen das. Und das ist ja wirklich so eine eigene, das ist wie eine eigene Buchstabe zu erfinden. Nur halt, dass der, auch ein Bild sagt ja auch mehr als tausend Worte. Du kannst ja sozusagen eine Kultur beeinflussen. Wer hat das F erfunden? Das sind Legenden. Das K. Alter! Die Aubergine. Was für ein krankes Schwein hat die Aubergine erfunden? Holy shit. Und der hat eine Kultur beeinflusst. Und es wird natürlich immer schwerer, weil es immer mehr Emojis gibt und immer mehr abgedeckt ist. Aber wir haben es uns zur Aufgabe gemacht, das Podcast-Ufo-Emoji-Projekt. Wir werden jeweils ein Emoji pitchen an diese Organisation und vorschlagen und wir werden schauen, ob es einer von uns beiden schafft. Und wer gewinnt, ist der bessere Mensch. Ist der bessere Mensch. Und kriegt die gesamten Patron-Einnahmen. Nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Man muss dazu sagen, dass wir in der Recherche gemerkt haben, dass es wirklich wahnsinnig viele Emojis gibt. Unfassbar. Es gibt fünf Hühner, es gibt wirklich, es gibt lächerlich viele Tiere, es gibt eigentlich alles, also jedes Wort, an das man zuerst denkt, also zuerst mal nicht die ersten 1500 Male, gibt es schon. Es ist lächerlich viel. Aber wir haben uns jetzt zwei Emojis ausgeducht. Du hast dich eines ausgesucht, ich habe mir eines ausgesucht. Und das werden wir pitchen. Wir werden nächste Woche, nee, übernächste Woche, werden wir vorbereiten. In unserem Pitch werden wir zunächst versuchen, euch damit zu überzeugen.
Und dann werden wir diese grossen Pitches dann an die Seite schicken und gucken mal, wer von uns beiden dann vielleicht sogar das so beiträgt, die ganze Kultur zu verändern. Wie gut wir das sind. Und wie die Pitches lauten, hören wir uns gleich an, nachdem ich mein Ladekabel geholt habe. Bis gleich. Man muss dazu sagen, wir haben schon eine Woche lang gegeneinander gepitcht, gegeneinander gekämpft, argumentiert, bis uns aufgefallen ist, dass es sowohl meine Idee, den Löffel, als auch deine Idee, die Strasse, bereits gibt. Ja, das stimmt. Heißt also, wir haben eine Woche lang mit dem Wissen, weil wir beide unser Betriebssystem nicht geupdatellet haben, gelebt, dass wir eine super Idee haben. Nope. Heißt, wir gehen jetzt, also Löffel wäre schon, wäre auf jeden Fall erste Reihe gewesen, Straße wäre auch erste Reihe gewesen, wir gehen jetzt acht Reihen zurück und pitchen jetzt unsere neuen Ideen. Florentin. Es kann natürlich relativ gut sein, dass der jeweils andere sofort sagt, ja, das gibt's auch. Meine Idee, für ein neues Emoji, ein Emoji, das vielleicht bald eure Tastaturen, eure Smartphones zieren wird und täglich benutzt wird, ist Männchen geht zur Tür raus. What? What? Männchen geht zur Tür raus, ist mein Emoji. Okay, jetzt will ich erst mein sagen und dann können wir genau argumentieren. Mein Emoji, mein Emoji, was wirklich um die Welt gehen wird und wirklich alle Leute beeinflussen wird in dem täglichen Schreiben und Handeln und was auch ein lustiges Partyspiel werden könnte, ist der Pokerchip. Oh, okay. Gefällt mir, gefällt mir. Steht natürlich für viel mehr als nur das Spiel Poker. Risiko, Einsatz, mal was wagen, all in gehen, gefällt mir richtig gut.
Wir lesen dann ... Weil ich finde, das muss vorbereitet sein.
Das muss gut sein, das muss wie ein kleines Referat sein,
das wir uns vorbereitet haben, um euch daraus zu überzeugen.
Deswegen würde ich sagen, machen wir das in zwei Wochen,
werden wir sowohl das Menti-geht-s-die-Tür-raus-
als auch die Pokerchips schön in so einem kleinen Pitch-Paper vorbereiten
und dann abschicken und gucken, was passiert.
Aber stellst du dir dabei so einen Stapel Pokerchips vor oder einen einzigen?
Einen einzigen, weil der kann auch zum Stapel werden.
Möchte ich mich noch nicht festlegen, ich finde Stapel auch nicht schlecht, aber kann auch zwei werden.
Also bitte an euch, bitte klaut uns das nicht, es ist tatsächlich nichts dabei, man kriegt kein Geld dafür, nur Prestige, es ist nur Arbeit für Prestige und um die Menschheit ein bisschen nach vorne zu bringen. Das, was wir heute nicht geschafft haben, durch unsere Astrophysikerin Anna Frebel, schaffen wir auf einem anderen Gebiet der Suche nach neuen Emojis. Finde ich nicht schlecht. Ich finde, es sollte auch so ein bisschen jetzt die Marschrichtung für das Podcast-Sofo sein, jede Woche auf eine gewisse Art die Menschheit zu beeinflussen. Und zu verbessern? Nee, zu beeinflussen. Negativ zu beeinflussen. Von mir auch. Nächste Woche, Frau Frebel, endlich ein Gespräch, was Deutschland umkehrend, was Deutschland mal so ein bisschen auf den Zahn fühlt, was ist schon da für Wissen, was fehlt noch, was kann man noch erreichen? Eine Bestandsaufnahme, haben wir schon? Eine Inventur, eine menschliche Wissensinventur. Eine Wissenschaftsinventur in Deutschland, mal hier im Podcastmarkt. Danach die Woche, Popkultur, Emojis, mal gucken, was danach die Woche kommt. Aber ich finde es cool, wenn wir jetzt jede Woche auf jeden Fall zumindest mal den Maßstab haben, die Welt zu verändern. Was mich aber interessiert, also mich interessieren viele Fragen, die ich sie nicht fragen würde, nicht weil es also nicht unangebracht wäre, sondern weil es halt ein bisschen verschwendet ist, weil sie so wahnsinnig viel weiss über Physik und über die Welt und das Universum. Aber ich denke mir oft, also das ist ja so ein bisschen das Klischee, dass es zum Beispiel wahnsinnig viele Studienfächer gibt, die eigentlich so scheißegal sind. So, das ist ja so ein bisschen so das Klischee, was du studierst, sibirische Ethnologie, das ist ja total doof. Aber auf der anderen Seite, und das ist doof, jeder soll da machen, was er will und was er cool findet, und da gibt es bestimmt viele interessante Dinge. Aber ich kann mir schon manchmal, mich würde schon mal interessieren, dass jemand, der wirklich sein gesamtes Leben der sibirischen Ethnologie gewidmet hat, nicht irgendwann sagt so, eigentlich ist das doch scheißegal, eigentlich interessiert das doch kein Schwein. Ja, oder er studiert seit 18 Jahren die Wissenschaft der Malediven. Und in ein paar Jahren gibt es die einfach nicht mehr, weil der Wasser im Meeresspiegel immer ansteigt und die nur einen Meter über dem Meeresspiegel liegen und dann weg sind. Das kann ja auch passieren. Ich meine, dass manche Dinge einfach dann weg sind. Mich würde einfach interessieren, wie Menschen ihre Arbeit finden. Neue Arbeit finden. Ihre Arbeit selbst wertschätzen oder für sinnvoll halten. Also irgendwie keine Ahnung, bei vielen ist es ja offensichtlich, jemand, der keine Ahnung Arzt ist oder Anwalt oder Müllmann oder so, da ist es ja völlig selbstverständlich, du machst ja was Gutes für alle anderen. Aber gerade so Forscher und Wissenschaftler, naja, aber du kannst es dir zumindest sagen. Wenn du morgen nicht aufstehen kannst, denkst du dir, okay, gut, irgendjemand muss den Müll wegbringen, fuck it, dann bin es ich halt, scheiß drauf, ich mach das jetzt. Aber wenn du keine Ahnung, ich glaube, es gibt bestimmt wahnsinnig viele Berufe, gerade so in Bürokratie, so irgendwie East Coast, Manager for Human Resource Availability Investment, wo man sich dann auch denkt, so eigentlich ist kommende der Bullshit. Und bestimmt auf vielen wissenschaftlichen Ebenen forscht man sich, also man muss ja nicht alles durch die Masse oder durch die Gesellschaft für argumentieren, zu sagen, nur weil viele Menschen es relevant finden, ist es relevant. Aber wie begründen die es sich vor sich selbst, zu sagen, das ist es, was ich den Rest meines Lebens machen will, reicht Spaß oder muss es mehr sein? Ich habe neulich in so eine Diskussion reingeschaltet, wo ich wieder am Anfang noch die Mitte noch das Ende gemerkt habe. Ich habe einfach nur kurz reingesäppt und dann wieder weggesäppt. Und da ging es einfach darum, dass Ärzte Prämien bekommen für manche Patienten, weil es halt Privatpatienten sind oder was auch immer. Und dann gab es die Diskussion, ob das egal ist oder ob das abgeschafft werden sollte. Und da hat ein Mann die Meinung vertreten, naja, Ärzte machen das ja, weil sie Leben retten wollen,
also ist das scheißegal und die können gerne Prämien bekommen.
Ein anderer meint, nope, natürlich geht es dann auch um Geld.
Und deswegen werden die Leute, die Geldbringen halt behandeln zunächst.
Und ich fand das so eindeutig und eine lächerliche Diskussion, als ob Ärzte, als ob die These auch nur ansatzweise vertretbar ist,
dass Ärzte das nur machen, um Leute zu retten.
Das ist doch Bullshit.
Das war's Bullshit. Natürlich geht es denen auch primär darum, cool, das ist ein cooles Argument, um sich vor sich selber zu argumentieren, warum man diesen Job macht und so und wie du schon sagst, jeden Morgen aufzustehen und zu sagen, ich rette ja Menschenleben und so. Aber was den Quatsch... Ja, ich glaube, es ist eine vielschichtige Motivation. Ich glaube, du fängst schon an, Arzt zu werden, mit dem Ziel, ich will was Gutes tun. Ich glaube, wenn du da mal irgendwie lange Arzt bist und du bist auch routiniert, dann kannst du mal sagen, ah, jetzt benutze ich dieses Medikament, um dafür mehr Geld zu bekommen, oder mache nur Privatpatienten, um mehr Geld zu bekommen. Aber es gibt auch Ärzte ohne Grenzen und so, weißt du? Es gibt auch sowas. Und ich glaube, wenn du anfängst ... Das sind die schlimmsten Leute, das sind ... Sorry, das ist eine falsche Meinung zu vertreten.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Das Medizinstudium ist, glaube ich, richtig brutal hart.
Und ich glaube, wenn du da nicht einen gewissen Idealismus hast, kommst du da auch nicht durch.
Wenn du nur Geld verdienen willst, dann mach halt irgendwie BWL-Banker-Broker-Bullshit.
Das ist, glaube ich, einfacher.
Naja, aber du hast dann nachher so eine Machtposition.
Im Medizinstudium ist da auch so ein kleines ...
Und dabei fällt mir das Mikrofon auf die Nase. auch so eine kleine Machtposition und so ein Statussymbol. Und ich meine, dafür gehst du auch gerne mal, läufst du doch mal die Extrarunde, um dann halt auch dementsprechend mehr Wissen zu haben, um dann so eine Praxis zu besitzen und so weiter. Das ist ja auch eine gewisse Machtposition, die du da erreichst. Weiß ich nicht. Also ich habe auf jeden Fall alles eindeutig, dass diese Prämien vollkommen für den Arsch sind, wenn man, keine Ahnung, ob das in der Debatte steht oder ob das gerade diskutiert wird, ob man das abschaffen sollte, aber ja, klar, da habe ich mal eine ganz konkrete Meinung, eine politische Meinung. Nicht schlecht. Ey, weißt du, wir haben mittlerweile so viele Hörer, dass wir, finde ich, auch mal so ein bisschen politisch werden müssen. Nein, das ist kein Fall. Doch, doch, an manchen Stellen müssen wir einfach mal eine Meinung. Ist jetzt egal,, du musst auch nicht ... Hauptsache irgendeine Meinung.
Ist auch nicht ...
Du musst ja auch irgendwie ...
Irgendwie begrünen.
Muss ja nicht sinnvoll sein.
Auch das war eine Meinung.
Ich glaube, es ist so richtig, richtig Hardcore-Leute
haben jemals hinterfragt, was sie machen.
So Beethoven denkt sich so, ja, aber die armen Kinder in Uganda,
für die mache ich halt gar nichts. Ich glaube, Uganda war kein Problem zur Beethoven-Zeit. Vielleicht eine andere Zeit einfach. Ganz kleinlaut. Ja, vielleicht. Wenn der Lehrer vorne steht, glaubt ihr eigentlich, also mit so erhobener Stimme, ja, war vielleicht einfach falsch. Habe ich mir diese Woche mal eingefallen, es gab eine Lehrerin bei uns in der Schule, die hatte ich auch im Unterricht, Deutsch ungefähr, und bei der wusste man immer schon, wenn man eine Antwort gegeben hat, ab der ersten Sekunde, dass sie richtig ist oder falsch. Und zwar, die stellt eine Frage so, ja was fühlt Effie Bries denn jetzt, wo irgendwie Krampas sie vergewaltigt hat? Und man sagt so, naja, einerseits, sie fühlt sich in der Ehe gefangen, aber auf der anderen Seite und die Lehrerin ab dem zweiten Satz fängt an den Kopf zu schütteln. Unterbricht dich nicht, lässt dich weiterreden, aber schüttelt auch vehement den Kopf und du so ja, aber natürlich ist es natürlich ein anderes Standesgefühl und natürlich das Wertgefühl einer Frau hängt natürlich auch an dem Stand des Mannes in der Zeit und natürlich ist sie froh, dass sie so einen Mann hat und bleibbar und die Kopf schüttelt und du denkst dir, soll ich jetzt aufhören zu reden oder lassen? Ja, aber du kannst auch dann noch die richtige Antwort geben. Du musst nur so rhetorisch so geschickt sein, dass du, obwohl du komplett falsch anfängst, noch mal den New Turn hinbekommst. Es ist so ein Heiss-Kalt-Spiel, sie schickt weniger den Kopf und dann oh, und sie, naja, natürlich hat es auch viel mit Religion zu tun, weil sie natürlich auch da sich und dann Und wird sich erst so ein Essay aufgesagt, einen perfekten Essay, hast du die Weltformel gelöst, weil sie das Heiss-Kalt-Spiel betreibt. Interessant, ich glaube, es ist ein Lehrertyp, weil das hatte ich auch, auch einige Lehrer machen das, und ich glaube, jetzt kommen die grossen fünf Lehrertypen. Oh Gott, nein! Typ typ fünf, der Typ, der den Kopf schüttelte, wenn man falsch liegt, bereits während man spricht, typ vier Leute, ich enthalte mich von diesem billigen Clickbait. Ne, das ist jetzt, so heißt auch die Folge, Top fünf Leute. Nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Die Folge heißt Unser erstes Mal. Wir rasten jetzt komplett aus. Mehr Hörer, wir brauchen noch mehr Hörer. Es gab diese Art Lehrer, die jemand anderen angucken, obwohl sie mit dir sprechen und dich offensichtlich so in den Wahnsinn treiben. Da hatten wir eine Musiklehrerin, die hat immer, der hat so eine Antwort gegeben und dann hat sie angefangen zu lachen, ha, und wie soll das aussehen, wie soll das dann passiert sein, ne, wie soll das dann, was soll diese Noten dann für eine Bedeutung gehabt haben, oder in der Zeit, aber halt da, weil die dich selber anguckt, sondern halt irgendein Mitschüler und so, und denkst so, fuck you einfach, das ist ein Arschloch, das hatten wir auch. Es gibt auch oft so manchmal bei so Vorträgen oder so Sachen, wo es ein recht großes Publikum gibt oder auch bei Stand-Up oder das ist auch manchmal so, dass man das Gefühl hat, fuck, der Performer hat sich mich rausgesucht und guckt mich immer an. Und dann steht man vor der großen Frage, weiche ich die mit's aus, lasse ich ihn hängen, dann mache ich ihn unsicher, dann denkt er, oh, ich finde es nicht lustig, aber ich will auch nicht die ganze Zeit angeguckt werden. Aber auf der anderen Seite, man merkt so, oh shit, ich habe den Punkt verpasst, das abzuwehren und jetzt bin ich die Person, auf die er sich bezieht, weil ich auch lache, aber jetzt komme ich da wieder raus. Ein bisschen selektive Wahrnehmung, weil du natürlich nur deine Perspektive kennst und dann auch wahrscheinlich die Momente am meisten auffallen, wo er dich anguckt, klar. Aber auf der anderen Seite, glaube ich, ist es bei mir wirklich so, weil ich bin, das habe ich mal untersucht, empirisch, ich bin gross, ich bin viel zu gross und durch meine Größe und ich habe so eine Taubeneigenschaft, so ein aufmerksames Herumgucken, weißt du, also ich bin ein sehr aufmerksamer Mensch, der viel aufnehmen will und viel sich umguckt und ich habe oft Augenkontakt mit Leuten, die sich auch umgucken, so auf Partys, wenn grosse Menschen, weil das ist auch so ein Ding, was grosse Menschen haben. Der Monorail-Effekt. Ja, der Leuchtturmeffekt, auch so ein bisschen, so Watchtower. Ich glaube, deswegen habe ich oft auch mit Leuten Augenkontakt, und das ist was, was sich bei mir eingeprägt hat, und deswegen habe ich das auch oft mit Lehrern, glaube ich, gehabt. Ich habe oft Augenkontakt, weil man aus der kleinen Schülermasse herausgestochen hat. Es ist schwierig, diese Folge ist auf Sand gebaut. Ja, Leute, das war eine Folge der Scham, der Enttäuschung, des Rückzuges, des Einigelns, aber auch der neuen Hoffnung für nächste Woche, wenn wir es jetzt endlich schaffen, in die Sterne zu schauen und an der Preiszeit teilzuhaben. Wir wollen die Antworten finden. Ey, das ist eine große Chance für uns alle da draußen. Wir sind nämlich alle ein Team, die große Podcast-Ufer-Community kann die Fragen stellen. Das ist aber noch für euch nochmal ein Aufruf. Wenn ihr nochmal Fragen habt, schickt uns die ruhig, wir gucken dann mal, was wir da noch Zeit haben zu stellen oder so. Einfach damit wir nochmal die Fragen beantworten können, auf die wir keine Antwort finden, wo auch Google nicht reicht.
Das ist doch schön.
Wir sagen Tschüss, bis nächste Woche, bis dahin, macht's gut,
es tut uns leid, aber manchmal scheitert man und manchmal geht's weiter.
Das war Florentin Will und Stefan Tietze.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss, wir heben ab. viel zu mehr